los misiles autopropulsados y guiados
que contienen una ojiva convencional o
nuclear pueden clasificarse de
diferentes maneras pero según su
trayectoria son balísticos y de crucero
los balísticos se disparan con mayor
frecuencia desde el suelo pero también
se pueden lanzar desde un submarino o un
avión su trayectoria parabólica le
permite volver a caer en picado a muy
alta velocidad sobre su objetivo los de
crucero se pueden disparar desde el
suelo el mar o un avión su trayectoria
en línea recta y a Baja altitud lo hace
difícil de detectar autopropulsado por
un reactor a lo largo de su trayectoria
es más preciso y más maniobrable pero
más lento que un misil balístico es más
fácil de interceptar los misiles
intercontinentales alcanzan una altitud
mayor a 100 kilómetros una velocidad
menor o igual a 24.000 kilómetros por
hora y como su nombre lo indica pueden
traspasar varias fronteras el lanzado
este viernes por Corea del Norte podría
teóricamente alcanzar territorio
estadounidense otro es el misil de
teatro que alcanza
solicitud de 50 kilómetros Mientras que
el misil de crucero llega a los 300
metros y alcanza una velocidad de 600 a
800 kilómetros por hora los misiles de
crucero como los balísticos pueden
cargarse con cabezas nucleares o con
cargas convencionales entre los misiles
balísticos conocidos están el Bora
teatro de fabricación turca el agni 4
indio el trailer 2 intercontinental de
Reino Unido el scalp eg francés el
Taurus kfd 350 que sueco alemán y el
cj10 que es chino la atención desatada
por el lanzamiento de misiles
intercontinentales por parte de Corea
del Norte ha hecho que china Llame al
diálogo mientras las alarmas en esta
región de Asia siguen prendidas ante una
eventual escalada